ما يحدث لاهل غزه اباده جماعيه يقولون
والكاميرات تثبت وتوثق ما يحدث في غزه
مجازر لم يشهد العالم مثيلا لها في تاريخه
القريب قول لا يجدي ما لم يسعفه فعل يستمر
العالم في وصف ما يحدث في غزه بانه جرائم
حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه
من يملك اذا وقف الحرب التي يضج العالم
بالدعوه الى وقفها سواء في الجمعيه العامه
الممثله بالفعل للامم المتحده او في
الشوارع المعبره عن الضمير
الانساني الى من يتوجه الامين العام للامم
المتحده والاحرار في العالم دولا وشعوبا
بالنداء حين يقولون اوقفوا الحرب تلك هي
انشغالات العالم اليوم في الشرق والغرب
لكن ثمت قوه واحده تملك ان تضغط على
اسرائيل لوقف الحرب
فتوقف انها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن امريكا عوضا عن التدخل لوقف
الحرب اختارت بان تكون طرفا فيها بالدعم
المالي والاستخباري وبالاساس ترسلها حمايه
لاسرائيل ودعما لها والدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه متهمه لانها ليست مهتمه
بالفلسطينيين يموتون بالقصف او بالموت تحت
الانقاض او بالجراح لا تضبيب لها وقد
انعدم الدواء او بالجوع والطعام الى نفاد
بسبب الحصار شاغل الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
هو ضمان سلامه رعاياها المحتجزين في غزه
منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي والهاجس
الاكبر لامريكا وحلفائها الغربيين هو
ترتيب وضع في قطاع غزه لا تشكل فيه حماس
خطرا على اسرائيل سواء تم ذلك بالقضاء على
حماس تماما او بحمل الفلسطينيين على
اللجوء خارج غزه وتضغط اسرائيل وتلح على
واشنطن وعلى الغرب ان يقنعوا مصر بقبول
هذا الاجراء ريث ما تنتهي الحرب اما
الفلسطينيون فيرفضون الخروج من غزه مهما
كان ثمن البقاء فيها فالذين جربوا الخروج
بامل في العو
لم يعودوا ابدا واكثرهم اهل غزه المهجرون
بعد نكبه عام
48 اما مصر فترى في هذه المقترحات خطرا
امنيا عليها وخطرا وجوديا على الفلسطينيين
انفسهم في رام الله حيث السلطه الفلسطينيه
تشاهد تقطيع لحم مواطنيها وشواه على
الهواء تبدو السلطه كانها ليست جزءا من
هذا الحريق انها تتابع ممسكه يديها وبنادق
بم ظنه ان الحرب في غزه هي حرب حماس
ولربما وجد الراعي الامريكي والاسرائيليون
في القضاء على حماس كخصم سياسي للسلطه ما
يفتح الطريق امام الذهاب في معالجه وفق
تصوراتهم للقضيه الفلسطينيه وربما وجدوا
في تلك السلطه خير ممثل لوهم الدوله
الفلسطينيه التي لن تقوم ابدا فالارض الف
ينيه قد نقصت في ظل السلطه اكثر مما نقصت
في غيابها ولم يكن غريبا والحال كذلك ان
تنال السلطه الفلسطينيه ثناء الولايات
المتحده وثناء اسرائيل التين تريان فيها
شرطيا يحرس الضفه الغربيه من ان تنفجر في
وجه اسرائيل اما المجموعه العربيه القليله
الحيله الكثيره الصمت الا فيما ندر فهي ما
تزال في حيرتها تتفرج على المحرقه
الفلسطينيه في غزه وتتفرج على عجزها الذي
اخرجها على كثرتها من ان تكون فاعلا في
التاريخ نروح وين الدول العربيه وين الدول
الاسلاميه بتفرجوا علينا بتفرجوا ما هو
عيب عليهم مش احنا من دمهم
ولحمهم ماذا بعد غزه ليس ثم غير الزلزله
الجيوسياسيه التي تكرس توسع اسرائيل في
راي المرا بين وتكمل احاطه الغرب امريكا
على وجه التحديد بالعالم العربي موارد
وبشرا وسياسات فحرب غزه لم تعر فقط مكياج
المقولات الكبرى من نحو فلسطين القضيه
المركزيه ولكنها عرت يقول الفلسطينيون
وجوها هم العدو حرب اسرائيل على غزه ليست
بلاء الفلسطينيين
وحدهم انها بلاء العرب في حيرتهم الوجوديه
الكبرى الواقفه بهم في حياه هي صنو
الموت